mais d'abord donc le phénomène roussel
avec norbert évangéliste à
il se présente comme le candidat de la
france heureuse de la bonne paye la
retraite à 60 ans et ça marche un
dernier sondage place fabien roussel
devant ses concurrents à gauche à 5% des
intentions de vote un résultat sur
lequel le candidat communiste surf en
tout allégresse je revendique le droit
au bonheur et je dis même que le bonheur
c'est contagieux une contagion certes
mais qui touche une france populaire qui
n'a pas cédé aux sirènes de l'extrême
droite mais loin de représenter
l'ensemble de l'électorat de gauche tous
ceux notamment pour qui le bonheur passe
avant tout par une politique écologique
qui n'a pas tout à fait sa place dans le
programme du pcf j'en ai marre mois
d'une gauche d'une gauche et des
écologistes qui donne des leçons de
morale qui vous culpabiliser qui vous
culpabiliser quand vous prenez la
voiture quand vous prenez l'avion quand
vous mangez de la viande qui vous traite
de raciste quand vous êtes pour le
nucléaire ou qui vous disent que vous
êtes raciste quand vous prenez un
drapeau bleu blanc rouge et bien moi ma
france et le drapeau rouge et le drapeau
bleu-blanc-rouge une provocation très
loin de rendre heureux le parti vert qui
dénonce la démagogie et l'archaïsme
d'une politique qui ne peut conduire
qu'à éloigné l'horizon d'une gauche
rassemblée le che hanno georges marchais
la normale à le modèle politique des
années 80
avec forcément les idées des années 80
qui vont avec un le nucléaire la bagnole
c'est forcément pas le projet que nous
importe qu'on soit à 4 à 5 ans et zuma
ce n'est pas la question la question
c'est comment on fait pour reconstruire
une gauche qui parle d'une même voix
avec les mêmes sans s'en créer des
clivages qui détruisent un peu les
rassemblements possible actuellement le
discours de fabien roussel c'est de
clive écrivait à gauche et ça c'est
dangereux pour l'avenir c'est dangereux
pour recréer une ré force de
gouvernement de gauche qui en fait
toutes les palettes de la gauche y
compris voilà la gauche communiste la
gauche écologiste en attendant le
candidat des jours heureux entend bien
jouer son rôle dès le premier tour et
qui sait dépasser le score des deux pour
cent atteints aux dernières élections
présidentielles
jusqu'où montera roussel les gros plans
sur les candidats de gauche dans ce
débat avec mes invités marion parisé
bonjour d'être secrétaire général du
think tank le millénaire qui se qualifie
je vous cite un de gaulliste réformateur
est guidé par l'intérêt national
florent radio bonsoir directeur du sim
tant que les théories enseignant à
sciences po
ils socialiste à périgueux également
pierre jacqmin être rédacteur en chef de
la revue regards avec nous en duplex
également céline pilates et essayiste
fondatrice de vivre la république et
vous publier ses biens essentiels dans
la collection bouquins bienvenue a aussi
laetitia copa éditorialiste politique
est à mes côtés bonsoir laetitia allez
un dernier alors les sondages évidemment
il faut il faut prendre les tendances me
regarde sondage opinionway pour radio
classique et les échos ce 15 février
jean luc mélenchon à 10% fabien roussel
à 5 comme yannick jadot ensuite on
trouve christiane taubira et l'hidalgo à
3% est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour
dire que tout simplement il ya une
percée fabien roussel je commence avec
vous marion parise et à une percée c'est
beaucoup dire mais en tout cas il ya un
phénomène fabien roussel qui est
intéressant puisqu'on voit une
finalement une guerre à gauche qui n'est
pas le temps une gare pour la présidence
mais pour l'image pour l'identité que se
construira la gauche après ses
présidentielle aujourd'hui l'électorat
de gauche
a un peu fait une croix sur la victoire
le candidat le plus avancé dans les
sondages c'est jean luc mélenchon mais
comme marine le pen il est sorti de 2017
avec son image très très esquinté et
aujourd'hui personne ne croit à sa
victoire par exemple au second tour
contre 1 emmanuel macron donc ce qui se
joue aujourd'hui c'est bien la
redéfinition de cette gauche et parmi
cette redéfinition on a un certain
nombre de cas de
deux candidats qui se positionne avec
des marqueurs idéologiques très fort des
marqueurs sur l'antiracisme des
marqueurs sur l'écologie et fabien
roussel indirectement il se retrouve un
peu le porteur de la gauche
traditionnelle est en cela il est évoque
peut-être même plus que anne hidalgo une
gauche classique florent lazio est ce
que finalement il s'est pas une sorte de
deux phares le mot est peut-être un peu
fort mais en tout cas eu
une balise pour des électeurs de gauche
y sont totalement déboussolée famille
roussel ont d'abord il ya un effet
d'optique parce que j'ai jamais vu une
campagne présidentielle commence et si
tardivement et je crois vraiment que les
règles d'équité du temps de parole vont
avoir une vraie vertu c'est de remettre
un tout petit peu de débat parce que sur
le terrain pour l'instant il n'y
personne ne fait campagne hormis les
communistes qui effectivement sont
partis très tôt cela étant dit il est
évident qu'il ya un phénomène médiatique
derrière fabien roussel qui à la fois le
fait des médias qui aime bien ce genre
de figure qu'on fait monter et descendre
au gré des envies et puis il ya un
discours politique qui est beaucoup plus
rassembleur que celui auquel le parti
communiste nous avait habitués c'est un
discours fille qui finalement face à
l'anxiété écologique décide de porter un
discours de positif de ne pas faire du
marqueur écologique un élément pivot du
discours idéologique ce qui est le cas
par exemple au sein du parti socialiste
ou d'europe écologie les verts
évidemment et donc qui de ce fait
reprend de l'électorat qui était un tout
petit peu perdu et qui retrouve des
marqueurs assez simple assez
réconfortant et de ce point de vue là il
agrège un électorat bien au delà de la
sphère d influence du parti communiste
mais est ce que vous diriez
pierre avec mâcon et quand même et on
dit souvent contré débat politique dans
cette émission dans la marge d'erreur
des sondages finalement quand ya des
écarts aussi aussi faible entre les
candidats ou est ce que vous pensez
qu'il ya quand même un engouement quoi
un petit phénomène sans doute un sondeur
vous dirais qu'il ya évidemment une
marge d'erreur maintenant je pense que
tous les sondeurs sont unanimes sur le
cac fabien roussel il se passe quelque
chose du côté de sa candidature et c'est
vrai que quand il a démarré sa
candidature il était à un pour cent et
demi pour cent et que là le voir dans
certains sondages qu'à 5% ça fait
presque 4 points 4 points demie de plus
que quand il a démarré donc oui
certainement il attire une nouvelle un
nouvel électorat je ne sais pas si c'est
un électorat populaire en revanche que
l'on constate c'est que une partie de la
gauche se retrouvent dans ce que dit ce
coup dans ce discours de fabien roussel
guy qui assumerait justement parlé le
langage qui touche les classes
populaires cette fameuse france des
barbecues qui était qui était annoncé
comme tel par
je voulais sont nicolas mathieu
l'écrivain nicolas mathieu qui a qui a
réveillé un peu ce spectre qui existent
aujourd'hui au tour de fabien roussel et
c'est vrai que le parti communiste comme
le parti socialiste ont été les deux
parties le plus structurant du 20e
siècle en tout cas à gauche et
qu'aujourd'hui il se bat aujourd'hui le
l'hégémonie et c'est toujours l'erreur
de la gauche et de vouloir jouer à l
hégémonie et est ce que vous disiez tout
à fait juste je pense que fabien roussel
a acté que la gauche ne gagnera pas
l'élection présentielle qu'il ne serait
pas lui-même président de la république
en revanche on sait que derrière
l'élection
présidentielle et les élections
législatives et donc le parti socialiste
qui a toujours était celui qui donnait
le ton dans les accords de qui va être
sur quelle circonscription bon bah le
parti communiste joue sa partition il
faut pas oublier une chose me souviens
de la dernière campagne électorale qui
était celle des européennes le parti
communiste avait fait une très belle
campagne avec ian brossât on peut pas
dire que ça s'est traduit véritablement
dans les dents les résultats à la fin
vous parliez de nicolas mathieu tiens
justement on en a sélectionné un extrait
de son interview dimanche sur france 5
on écoute le lauréat du dernier
goncourt pour connemara
c'est bien qu'ils aient une gauche
hypokhâgne lyrique érudite ouverte sur
le monde c'est bien aussi qu'il ya une
gauche bac trop il s'intéresse aux gens
qui bossent dans les entrepôts au petit
veau infirmières
gens qui conduisent des camions des
camionnettes dans les petites villes etc
les gens se sentent à la fois dédaigné
souvent méprisée dans leurs habitudes
peut-être culpabiliser et là il inverse
le rapport de forces est à dire que le
ricanement se retourne quoi et que ouais
je pense que ça m'oblige j'ai vraiment
entendu des gens autour de moi trouvé ça
vraiment super quoi une france des
barbecues oui laetitia un mot moi je
trouve que c'est sidérant que on se
rende compte là à deux mois même pas
deux les promoteurs de la présidentielle
qu'il faut parler à ces gens là je vous
rappelle qu'il ya quand même la france
qui était à feu et à sang avec les gilet
jaune que le pouvoir a été incapable
d'établir le moindre dialogue alors si
vous pourvoyez un gamin du grand débat
on peut considérer que c'était leur
faute il ya eu une tentative en tout cas
c'était le président c'est surtout le
président
discours du président mais
je te prend franchement je trouve que
moi il ya eu vraiment ça a été le gros
échec du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
c'est être incapable de parler et
établir le contact avec cette france là
mais qui empêchait l'opposition de le
faire cesser des rentes entendre ça ah
ben c'est bien qu'il y en ait qui parle
aux chauffeurs de camion bah oui enfin
je t'en fait il qu'il
peut pas dire que s'ils se mobilisent
encore aujourd'hui que par exemple elle
a mobilisé son gilet jaune est aboutie
d'une manière ou d'une autre aujourd'hui
au convoi de la liberté c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de traduction politique vers
laquelle ils ont envie dalé et donc ça
c'est aussi l'échec de la gauche fabien
roussel la d6 menu cinq ans
mais il ya les catégories populaires on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui les écologistes
et 7,2 orienter leurs discours sur les
catégories sociales supérieures jean luc
mélenchon à peu près pareil y compris
les jeunes mais la gauche est fracturée
mais aussi elle est fracturée dans les
rectorats qu'elle veut séduire alors que
la gauche aurait vocation à travailler
aujourd'hui 100 chez marine le pen oui
pour partie à partie alors je veux
donner la parole tout de suite assainies
pina qu'on n'a pas entendu dans ce débat
mais je voudrais remettre ces c'est
d'abord ses bons sondages dans une
perspective historique on est évidemment
très très loin des années 60-70 le plus
haut score d'un candidat communiste à la
présidentielle
c'était c'était jacques duclos
1969 un joyeux robert 21
10 c'est mon époque soit là jacques
duclos 21 27% en 1969 bon il montera
évidemment pas aussi au sénat et ce
qu'il peut d'après vous titiller jean
luc mélenchon voilà ce flirter avec les
10 comment vous voyez cette cette
campagne de famille roussel comment vous
l'analysez
elle est compliquée parce que il et il
se retrouve aussi dans une situation
dans lequel aujourd'hui la gauche ne
joue même plus sa place au second tour
il est hors de question bien sûr de
gagner la présidentielle mais met d'être
présent au second tour est quasiment une
ambition qu en tout cas les électeurs ne
pense pas avoir réalisé donc aujourd'hui
ce qui se joue c'est la reconstruction
de la gauche ce qu'on voit malgré tout
c'est que la gauche qu'on peut appeler
wac est encore extrêmement hégémonique
et qu'en fait fabien roussel représente
une gauche effectivement classique qui
est finalement le
fait d'abord choisi comme slogan les
jours heureux qui est qui rappelle le
conseil national de la résistance en
renvoie finalement aux fondamentaux de
la gauche autrement dit à l'égalité à la
quête de justice sociale à une gauche
des travailleurs ce qui est exactement
la gauche le l'électorat qui avait
abandonné notamment le parti socialiste
mais pas que
le parti écologique aussi n'est pas un
parti qui est investi sur les
travailleurs donc il est très
intéressant de voir que le retour de ce
discours ramène un électorat et touche
largement au delà de ce qui était devenu
le petit électorat résiduelle du pc le
problème c'est que c'est pour l'instant
une position assez personnel malgré tout
de fabien roussel que par exemple dans
le sens dans le communisme municipal
les élections se jouent beaucoup sous
une sur une forme de clientélisme et que
ce cri enter the moon is me lie est
encore très fort et qu'à l'intérieur du
pc il ya quand même des tensions par
rapport à la ligne que tente d'imposer
fabien roussel
ça c'est le sens d'une tribune cosignée
notamment dans figaro parue dans les
pages débats du figaro c'est une pina
donc vous nous dites il dérange genre à
dire je reviens au jour donne la parole
ça près il dérange une partie de la
gauche la gauche soit qui disait céline
pina 5,6 est d'accord avec ça oui
faisait toujours les mots de la droite
sur la gauche donc ça ça m'amuse de voir
effet oui mais c'est un peu les mots de
famille roussel je reprends on l'a
entendu le sujet tout à l'heure j'en ai
marre de cette gauche qui nous
culpabiliser lorsqu'on prend la voiture
qu'on mange de la viande qui nous
insultent parce que nous sommes pour le
nucléaire je souhaite porter une gauche
populaire qui tient un drapeau tricolore
et le drapeau rouge en même temps mais
il n'a pas prononcé les mots la gauche
vauxaillon c'est vraiment je
sais ce que je gère mon jardin de c'est
ce que je répondais à votre première
question effectivement il a décidé de
montrer que la kz pivotal de sa campagne
n'est pas l'écologie et qui ne soumet
pas tout son prisme idéologique toutes
ses réponses aux classes populaires à
l'écologie ça ne veut pas dire qu ils
l'abandonnent ça veut dire que il décide
de faire une hiérarchie des choix et
donc il n'ya pas n'y a pas de mots
qu'ils mouillent à il n'y a rien de tout
cela il y a juste une hiérarchie des
choix une hiérarchie de léo de
l'idéologie qui est assez conforme
d'ailleurs avec le discours du comice il
faut pas s'amuser à ré redécouvrir le
communisme parce qu'il ya un petit côté
huron on re découvre
chez fabien aussi un discours sur la
laïcité qui est très été très clair
c'est ce que disent et bin adam solvants
dans sa tribune il est lui très clair
sur la laïcité peut-être que christiane
taubira l'a été un peu moins dans
certains dans certains discours à
l'éclair mais dans une autre mesure
c'est ça que vous voulez dire mais je
pense que fabien roussel a une cohérence
une cohérence qui aujourd'hui surprend
parce que ils cherchent moins des
segments électoraux cas ressouder une
base est donc cette cohérence elle et
elle est assez facilement décelable les
autres partis on le voit son le nez rivé
sur des sondages qualitatifs et essayer
de voir quel segment électoral ils
peuvent essayer de séduire les classes
moyennes donc bon politel discours les
classes supérieures ont poli tel
discours etc et donc mais encore une
fois elle n'oublions pas qu'il ya un
effet d'optique ster que ya un candidat
qui a un socle électoral faible et qui
essayent d'unifier son socle électoral
alors que les autres partis de gauche
qui certes sont très faibles étaient
dans une volonté de parti majoritaire et
de ce fait là et aident beaucoup plus
dans la trappe tout ce que la science
politique appelle les parties attrape
tout est donc en juge aujourd'hui des
partis qui avaient une vocation
majoritaire dans une forme de difficulté
qu'on espère transitoire en tout cas que
j'espère transitoire et qui
effectivement créé une décorrélation
entre le discours habituel le discours
électoral habituel et la réalité
concrète de ce discours là voilà je
pense que la cohérence elle est facile à
trouver quand il y avait une partie
beaucoup plus simple à diriger face à un
segment électoral très identifiée marion
paraissait un discours de droite de dire
qu'il ya une gauche aux pistes pas
forcément non mais laisse qu'on voit
vraiment c'est que la gauche paye les
pots cassés de son de sa bascule de 2012
le rapport terra nova quel électorat
quelle majorité électorale pour 2012 où
il avait fait le choix de se dire la
classe ouvrière est en déclin tournons
nous vers l'avenir l'avenir et en une un
électorat plutôt jeune féminisé plutôt
tournés progressistes sur les questions
sociales et tournait finalement ouvert
mondialisation or aujourd'hui cet
électorat soyons honnêtes il se retrouve
cet électorat de gauche en tout cas se
retrouvent principalement plutôt chez
emmanuel macron et dans le monde dans
une gauche ou alors ils autrefois tout
simple voilà ils étaient engagés dans
des associations est perdu il ne sait
pas il ne se retrouve pas et c'est le
beau le cas de beaucoup d'électeurs de
gauche soit ils se retrouvent au mieux
dans un moindre mal chez emmanuel macron
et c'est bien ça la difficulté au final
quel la question qui se pose c'est quel
est le projet au 21ème siècle de la
gauche le projet du xxème siècle c'était
les acquis sociaux aujourd'hui les
acquis sociaux ont largement progressé
ils ne sont plus en accord avec le temps
pour une grosse partie en tout cas
l'idéologie du xxème siècle n'est plus
en accord avec les problématiques
actuelles et donc ils doivent se
repenser les écologistes essaye de le
faire en abordant le prisme en adoptant
le prisme de l'écologie de
l'environnement pour faire une lecture
de la société mais c'est une lecture qui
est totalement partiel est aujourd'hui
qui ne convainc pas parce qu'elle reste
décorrélée d'une capacité à gouverner et
à gouverner plus largement sur
l'ensemble des thématiques parce qu'ils
apparaissent vraiment comme finalement
une augmentation d'une association
augmenter une association politique plus
qu'un parti politique du gouvernement
alors je vous propose deux on vient
parler longuement de fabien roussel on
va parler christiane taubira maintenant
laetitia vous avez analysé la
candidature taubira pour vous c'est un
paradoxe oui parce qu'elle a été portée
par le peuple pour se lancer dans la
course et une fois qu'elle y était elle
a été lâchée donc c'est complètement
paradoxal et pourtant sa partie plutôt
bien dommage puisque christiane taubira
c'est la candidate de cette primaire
populaire cet élan populaire citoyens
qui est quand même une grande tendance
de notre époque regardez emmanuel macron
avec sa convention citoyenne sur le
climat il avait tenté comme ça d'y
répondre bon avec les réponses que l'on
connaît mais en tout cas cette primaire
populaire bien qu'elle fût un peu a dans
son fonctionnement discutable avait le
mérite deux horizons horizontale ise la
société c'est à dire qu' on n'est plus
dans une pouvoir qui est pyramidal on
redonne du pouvoir au peuple à la
société et c'est une demande quand on
discute vraiment avec tous les électeurs
c'est vrai que c'est quand même une
demande ne demande qu'à ses constantes
donc ça partait quand même bien trois
cent mille électeurs c'est quand même
énorme quand on voit que l air congrès
étaient 113 180 113000 à vous
internautes à voter donc on peut se dire
qu'il ya quand même cet élan populaire
derrière cette candidature qui guide
cette campagne s'est pas beaucoup si on
regarde en arrière
il va se passer quelque chose elle a une
légitimité populaire christiane desbiens
et finalement non parce que puisque la
prit puisque alors l'une des infos du
jour c'est que le parti radical de
gauche fait marche arrière oui bah il a
lâché ses seins taubira sans le dire
alors ça c'est vraiment très étrange
aussi en politique parce que c'est pas
dit de façon cachée et radicale mais on
le comprend et donc christiane taubira
répond un peu bravache hier sur twitter
en disant que c'est une péripétie dans
un moment crucial pour le pays la vérité
thomas séquelles à 73 promesses de
parrainages alors qu'il en faut 5 sens
et qu'elle est la plus que vingt jours
maintenant pour aller à la course des
parrainages donc elle se fait lâcher par
un parti politique et autre signe qui
montre quand même que sa campagne prend
l'eau le message qu'elle a posté par
vidéo sur twitter aussi regarder
bein notre campagne est une campagne
citoyenne elle a commencé grâce à vous
et vous est pleinement engagée autour de
nos valeurs et de nos convictions
partagées elle porte d'ailleurs votre
empreinte et les joyeuses libre
vigoureuse et rigoureuse dynamique
populaire en attendant les 500
parrainages nos moyens sont limités
aussi je viens vous informer que nous
avons lancé un appel aux dons et je
viens vous demander votre contribution
aussi modeste soit elle c'est compliqué
quand on commence à appeler aux dons
après c'est un élan qui est assez
cohérent si les citoyens l'ont porté
dans la campagne ils peuvent aussi
l'aider parce qu'on sait qu'il faut bien
sûr avoir des assises financières
solides donc
ben ce n'est pas son moment visiblement
à christiane taubira c'est pas vraiment
de sa faute il me semble puisque quand
on additionne tous les votes de gauche
le peuple de gauche atteint péniblement
les 25% et on voit bien que cette
élection se fera apparemment plutôt à
droite donc vous savez c'est la
politique c'est vraiment un moment cédé
question de timing de moments elle elle
pensait que c'était sa fenêtre enfin et
elle s'est complètement trompé
effectivement il ya une question de
finances pierre jacqmin il faut pas
l'oublier d'entendre dans cette histoire
le le recul du parti radical de gauche c
c'est aussi le financement de la très
courte certes campagne de christiane de
bien mais quand même campagne et kimi et
s'évapore oui c'est important le
l'argent pour pouvoir engager des
meetings des déplacements pour pouvoir
faire de la communication évidemment le
paradoxe comme disait laetitia de
christiane taubira séquelles sa
candidature repose sur légitimité
presque inédite à gauche parce que c'est
un mouvement citoyen qui apportait sa
candidature parce qu'ils étaient pas la
sienne d'ailleurs inquiété l'objectif de
porter une candidature commune de toute
la gauche c'est elle qui finit par
obtenir le suffrage majoritaire
même si c'est sur la base d'un consensus
avec des airs bien pas bien insuffisant
les notes qui était donné à chacun des
candidats et le paradoxe il est que l
est aussi une femme seule c'est à dire
qu'elle est peu entouré il y avait
modestement le parti radical de gauche
qui vient de l'abandonner mais on sait
aussi pour quelle raison il abandonnait
c'est pour des raisons assez vieille
comme la politique est vieille et ses
déliés bonne logique boutiquière où on
sait que derrière en fait les les petits
élus du prg il ya des circonscriptions à
prendre et que c'est pas écrit cento
dira qu'ils finiront par les avoir et
que donc du coup ce qui s'est joué à
travers la défection du parti radical de
gauche de christiane taubira c'est que
derrière et des manipulations politiques
avec sans doute une partie europe
ecologie les verts pour avoir des
circonscriptions sans doute une partie
du parti socialiste pour avoir d'autres
circonscriptions est ce qui se joue
c'est une manipulation c'est d'être
réputation c'est d'être association des
vieux comme la police
christiane taubira même pas et c'est la
raison pour laquelle elle s'inscrit dans
cette dynamique et l amtri de la
primaire populaire est ce que ne voulait
pas la primaire populaire donc c'est
pour ça qu'il ya un paradoxe est à dire
qu'elle à la fois la légitimité presque
la plus grande légitimité à gauche parce
qu'elle a presque 400 mille personnes
votants qui ont soutenu ce à quoi qui
n'ont pas consulté sa candidature mais
qui ont obtenu la candidature de
christiane taubira et en même temps
c'est une femme seule c'est une femme
seule et qui a fait une entrée en
campagne ces mauvaises on vous souvenez
le soir où elle est investie à les
expliquer la campagne qu'elle va gagner
2002 un l'élection de il ya vingt ans à
la rentrée face en audition avec la
fondation abbé pierre elles sèchent sur
des questions qui sont les quais sont
structurantes à gauche on attend la
gauche on a tout les atouts de la boule
10ème il y en a ras-le-bol en parle que
d'identité d'immigration de sécurité
elle a là une occasion de réintroduire
un peu de gauche et d'avoir un discours
fondateur de gauche à un moment de
campagne vous pouvez voir une bascule
elle rate son entrée en campagne donc ça
devient très très compliqué et puis
aller sur des parrainages on sait aussi
que le parti socialiste les formations
politiques les partis politiques sont
friend et de faire pour pouvoir empêcher
les élus de parrainer et de marrainer
christiane taubira on va dire est ce
qu'il ya un voile a eu une action du
parti socialiste est ce que vous êtes
secrétaire nationale 2 pour freiner
empêcher la candidature de christine
taubira mais je crois qu'on peut pas
reprocher aux élus socialistes d'
apporter leurs parrainages alors
candidate socialiste et que quand on est
dans un décompte qui est médiatique est
ritualisée de chaque semaine de savoir
combien on a de parrainage est donc
d'arriver à jauger la puissance d'un
candidat ou en fonction de ses
parrainages peut pas reprocher un parti
structuré de parrainer sa candidate ça
je pense que j'ai moi j'aimais le nombre
de parrainages suffisants mais parce
qu'on l'avait mocratie mais parce que
les muses pardon de lire il ya eu des
mains tendues des refus donc on peut
essayer de revenir sur l'histoire il se
trouve qu'il ya une candidate socialiste
que les élus socialistes défendent leur
candidat elle a dépassé les 1000
parrainage samedi qu'elle ne manque pas
non mais valérie pécresse est à plus de
1500 ce que je veux dire on peut aussi
demander à chris kiah mais mais mais ça
serait élection est très imprécis ça
swingue
une preuve de philanthropie mais comme
disait oscar wilde et philanthrope perte
de tout sens de l'humain non je voudrais
dire un point c'est que la candidature
de christiane taubira c'est un ego trip
et que le principe d'un ego trip c'est
qu'on est seul et que là je pense que de
christiane taubira elle est en train de
sortir de son ego trip ces
violences parce que elle a voulu être
hors des partis très bien mais les
parties amène des parrainages et du
financement elle a voulu s'abstraire de
toute base idéologique et programmatique
très bien elles sèchent sur à peu près
tous les sujets on ne peut pas envisager
de faire une campagne aussi tardive en
étant sur un chemin de 2,2 pénale de
même un petit peu parce qu'elles
bénéficiaient de la bienveillance et de
soutien médiatique parce que christiane
taubira c'est un personnage dans le
feuilleton présidentielle et moi à
étonner c'est que les médias non non bon
loba plus d'invités que ça mais pas
parce que le rebond dit que ça sur ça
parce que tu le talent sans le travail
pardon de le dire ça ne m'allait le
travail est là quand même 10 ne sais pas
ça ne sert à ça ne s'est pas vu
oui là là on est auparavant peut-être
mais en tout cas là je pense qu'on est
dans une campagne 1préparer et qui
n'arrivent pas à se restructurer et le
dernier message en termes de marketing
politique les dévastateur parce que au
lieu de faire le point sur ces
parrainages de faire un appel à françois
bayrou qui a proposé la bande des bars
et nagent etc on est à nouveau sur cette
fuite en avant qui consiste à continuer
vaille que vaille dans une logique
d'affrontement permanent ce qui la
caractérise qui fait son panache mais
qui pour une présidentielle n'est pas
adapté céline pina est ce que christiane
taubira ces sept là la gauche rock dont
vous parlez dans votre tribune
en tout cas elle fait une erreur de fond
christiane taubira c'est que le prg la
seule identité qui restait au prg
s'étaient justement un rapport à une
laïcité extrêmement fort une laïcité
sans adjectif est la première sortie
qu'elle fait vise justement à un tir un
peu à balles réelles sur cette forme de
laïcité donc elle ne pouvait que crispé
son parti et surtout l abandonner une
forme d'identité qui aurait pu sur
laquelle elle aurait pu avoir un
discours en tout cas donc ça je pense
que c'était une erreur et l'autre erreur
c'est que malgré tout cette y avait pas
vraiment des non citoyens c'est à dire
que c'est parti sur une idée qu'il
fallait une candidature unique il
fallait un rassemblement de la gauche et
ça très très mal commencé puisque des
gens sont trouvés candidats sans vouloir
l'être puisque il ya eu on n'a pas
oublié le jeune homme se grippent dos
qui faisant à
une
chat vidéo expliquant qu'en fait le but
du jeu était de siphonner les autres
partis il y avait quelque chose d'
extrêmement agressif aussi dans cette
candidature qui ne pouvait pas passer ce
qui voulait dire qu'avant même de
démarrer vous aviez tiré dans le dos de
tout ce qui pouvait être vos alliés ou
en tout cas des gens avec qui vous étiez
censés rentrer en dialogue tout ça ne
pouvait que très mal se terminer et plus
généralement peut-être un peu plus dans
son analyse cette campagne au delà de la
gauche mais est ce que la gauche n'est
pas en train ou a pas perdu la bataille
des idées dans cette campagne
présidentielle tout simplement peut-être
par manque de travail vous parliez de du
travail de christiane taubira m'ont
peut-être on peut aussi retourné
l'argument et vainqueur en tout cas la
gauche les grande partie des partis de
gauche et c'est ce qui fait la
différence fabien roussel a choisi de
renier les totems qui faisait vraiment
sa différence jusqu'à maintenant la
question de l'égalité à la question du
travail la question l'aladi de la
laïcité l'égalité il ya le tout la
partie communautarisme qui a pris le
dessus sur la question du travail on a
beaucoup de références à des questions
qui relèvent plus de l'assistance que de
la valorisation du travail et sur la
laïcité c'est pareil on a vraiment des
distinctions qui sont fondamentales donc
aujourd'hui comme je le disais tout à
l'heure c'est la question
de la gauche c'est qu'elle gauche au 21e
siècle et la gauche au 21ème siècle ne
veut pas être une poursuite de ce
qu'elle était au 20e siècle les enjeux
sont différents aujourd'hui on a un
retour des conflits entre les
superpuissances
et si on se contente de vouloir
simplement aligné
les individus et de mettre l'individu au
coeur de la sauce du projet de société
sans avoir une réflexion sur l'état la
nation ce qu'elle peut porter c'est voué
à un échec est ce que le la grille de
lecture de la gauche et est datée c'est
un peu ce que ce que je retiens de cette
fervente et moi je vois qu'il ya 14000 6
% de personnes qui vivent en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté il ya 4,1 millions de
personnes qui sont mal logées la
promesse zéro sdf dans la rue c'est pas
le cas on a aujourd'hui des gens qui
meurent plus tôt en fonction du métier
qu'ils exerçaient et on voit qu'un cadre
supérieur il vit plus longtemps à la
retraite qu'un ouvrier donc je veux bien
qu'on dise que le discours et date-là en
tout cas la réalité elle elle est
immuable et on voit que les rapports
sociaux eux n'ont pas changé et ça
devrait porter les oui mais de la gauche
moi j'entends j'entends le réquisitoire
qui est fait sur une gauche qui n'a pas
travaillé et c'est jean luc mélenchon a
travaillé mais non mais à son programme
dont il est nourri les après le même
parti non mais tous les partis ont
travaillé on peut juger le travail
mauvais pas adaptés etc mais tous les
partis ont travaillé le parti socialiste
a fait une un long travail
programmatique jean luc mélenchon l'a
fait l'europe écologie l'a fait sur
plein de sujets notamment sur les
questions de sécurité c'est pas du tout
le même discours 2017 2022 mais posons
nous la question de d'abord de
l'incapacité de la gauche de se faire
entendre pendant un quinquennat et ça
c'est en partie le jeu des institutions
sous la vème république quand vous êtes
ultra minoritaire vous rester ultra
minoritaire et il ya eu cet effondrement
qui a créé aussi un effet de deux de
blast qui fait que les partis n'ont pas
su remonter en selle et puis
effectivement il ya eu des errements
déshérence qui n'ont pas aidé à la
gauche à se repositionner mais n'allons
pas faire un procès totalement inique je
pense que il ya eu des choses qui ont
été faites pas suffisamment la preuve en
est que les résultats ne sont pas les
bons + parti s'est demandé hier c'est la
droite avait pas manqué aussi travail
programmatique crier c'est pas ça touche
pas seulement la gauche quant à cantat
qu'elle met peut nous rejoindre tout de
suite bonsoir quentin bienvenu pour un
récit parce que la candidate socialiste
anne hidalgo étaient tous au sénat ce
matin et vous avez pu la suivre oui tout
à fait elle descendait tout juste 1 de
l'agent qui l'a amené des antilles où
elle vient de passer trois jours et donc
ce matin infections elle est venue rend
une visite à l'occasion du la réunion du
groupe des sénateurs socialistes avaient
sont une soixantaine au sénat c'est un
groupe assez importante et même une
dizaine de députés qui ont fait le
déplacement pour l'occasion et c'était
aussi un moment pour affirmer que et
bien les socialistes sont je cite la
première force parlementaire de gauche
voyait cette photo de famille un peu
général avec aussi un parti de
gouvernement ont bien voulu redire aussi
et les sénateurs ce matin et donc à la
clé cette photo de famille et un petit
échange avec la candidate écoutez
c'est une photo en action ça c'est pas
encore les souvenirs là on est
à la conquête donc non non les souvenirs
on verra plus tard voilà les la
candidate capes au total une heure
trente avec ses parlementaires ce matin
au sénat avec une discussion qui a
beaucoup tourné autour du fonds du
programme avec des remontées aussi des
élus parfois ceux qui étaient en visio
des remontées de terrain aussi sur les
difficultés programmatique et ce climat
général les mauvais sondages commencent
ont-ils vécu mais c'est vrai thomas que
le jdd à calculer la moyenne des
différents sondages sur une semaine et
qu'elle donnait à 2 4% d'intentions de
vote sur cette moyenne alors tout à
l'heure quand on lui a demandé si la
rencontre avec les parlementaires
étaient l'occasion de reprendre aussi un
peu de souffle eh bien ces questions ça
a semblé un peu lagacé écoute à nouveau
cet échange alors comment vous dire le
souffle j'en ai voit là et je n'ai pas
besoin chaque jour de reprendre un
nouveau souffle non c'est une réunion de
travail que nous vendons de fer avec des
parlementaires engagés le sénat
l'assemblée des parlementaires qui ont
beaucoup travaillé qui sont des experts
de beaucoup de sujets que vous fixez une
évolution dans la campagne avec eux
objectif à atteindre peut-être être 1 6%
d'opinions
gagner gagner
et bien la dynamique nous la
construisons jour après jour et vous
verrez vous aurez sûrement des surprises
well and isago qu'elle soit a coupé
court à lyn thériault en avez d'autres
questions n'a pas pu elle est posée elle
était effectivement apparemment agacé un
d'être toujours ramené systématiquement
à cette question des sondages et
voyelles et donc partie du sénat ce
moment là on a pu ensuite discuté avec
les présidents de groupe mais sans la
candidate ps merci quentin pour ce récit
florent radio c'est vrai que ces voix là
quand on est dans une campagne qui va
dire ne décolle pas
ça doit être dur même psychologiquement
d'être tout le temps ramenée à cette
question des sondages est-ce que comment
vous vous le voulez percevez ses mauvais
scores pour c'est ce qu'ont pensé tiens
quelle est sous-évaluée et
éventuellement je sais bien que tous les
candidats qui sont à moins de 5 10 1
mais bon deux aspects d'abord un aspect
plus de ressenti moi vous savez je suis
resté au parti suisse depuis très
longtemps donc en 2010 est de 2017 à
2019 les gens à nous horrifier à la
figure en disant mais vous êtes mort
vous ne le savez pas vous continuez bon
il se trouve que de 2019 à 2020 on a
montré qu'on avait un tout petit peu de
puissance sous la aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya une passe compliquée
et je crois aussi que il ya un effet
autoroute auto-entretenue des sondages
qui fait que plus on est faible - en et
mobilisateur je crois néanmoins que la
partie médiatique qui vient de se jouer
n'est pas une partie où la gauche et est
audible ou écouté et je crois que
l'égalité du temps de parole changer
considérablement la donne puisque la
gauche va pouvoir porter la voix qui est
la sienne sa musique ses tonalités ces
thèmes de combat d'une part et je crois
enfin que d'un il faut il faut expliquer
peut-être pour l'instant on est dans
l'équité donc l'équité elle est calculée
un peu aussi en fonction des résultats
dans les sondages c'est sale et lorsque
la campagne officielle va commencer
chaque candidat aura le même temps de
parole et je crois vraiment que ça va
changer la donne j'ajoute un dernier
point c'est que le socle électoral du
parti socialiste et j'avais eu
l'occasion de le dire sur votre plateau
est plus élevée évidemment qu'à 1,5 je
pense qu'on peut le mètre minimum
celui qui était son score aux
européennes qui est de 6,2 donc je crois
que ça laisse une capacité de rebond
tada puisque le terme avait été utile
croyez encore qu'à peut gagner non
gagnés en seul nom avec une union de la
gauche tout est possible je pense qu'il
faut rester totalement ouvert sur cette
possibilité là voyons les scores lorsque
l'égalité du temps de parole viendra
mais le parti socialiste n'a jamais
gagné seul dans les dernières années je
crois que le discours sur l'union de la
gauche et un invariable et un horizon
désirable prudence avec les sondages
c'est une photographie à l'instant t on
le dit régulièrement marion parisé est
ce que c'est d'autant plus vrai pour
l'électorat populaire d'une certaine
façon très qui se mobilisent
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est
vraiment un des sujets pour la gauche
notamment c'est que il y a encore une
possibilité pour les candidats de gauche
de voir leurs intentions de vote
augmentés parce que l'électorat
populaire qui est traditionnellement
celui qui votent le plus à gauche se
mobilise tardivement parce que moins
politisés parce que préoccupés par
d'autres thématiques jusqu'au dernier
moment c'est pour ça aussi qu'on avait
vu déjà en 2017 jean luc mélenchon
grimper dans les sondages jusqu'au
jusqu'au dernier moment sur les
dernières semaines ça s'est joué très
tardivement hélas ce phénomène est
encore accélérée ou en tout cas
amplifiée par la crise due qu'au guide
mais là où je mettrais peut-être une
nuance sur cette capacité justement à
mobiliser plus sur cette dernière ligne
droite ça repose sur deux choses d'une
part pour mobiliser plus il faudrait
qu'il y ait le sentiment de pouvoir
avoir une utilité au vote cette utilité
elle est compliqué aujourd'hui parce que
là encore le meilleur candidat c'est
jean luc mélenchon et jean luc mélenchon
aujourd'hui il n'apparaît pas comme
quelqu'un pouvant gagner cette élection
présidentielle donc ça démobilise encore
plus un électorat qui déjà a du mal à
s'impliquer dans l'élection
présidentielle est deuxième deuxième
point c'est donc qu'on a un certain
nombre de d'électeurs qui pourrait tout
simplement faire un choix autre
peut-être de voter contre la droite en
choisissant emmanuel macron ou
simplement pour un autre candidat
peut-être même de droite pour se
débarrasser la lada emmanuel mac
contestataires mais c'est marginal mais
ça peut
c'était jusqu'à les analyser mais pierre
jacqmin on peut aussi failli il ya aussi
ce que représente la candidature d'eric
zemmour pour une partie des électeurs de
gauche il est en train là dans une
tendance on essayait de plus regardez
les dynamiques en train de grappiller
petit à petit est-ce qui peut servir de
mobilisateur des faits mobilisateur pour
une partie des électeurs de gauche en
disant il faut quand même qu'on se
mobilise qu'on aille voter quant à elle
voter pour des candidats de gauche pour
contre eric zemmour ou est-ce que ce
scénario vous ne croyez pas j'aimerais y
croire je ne sais pas s'il faut
désespérer de la bouche d'ailleurs comme
le l'écrit ce livre que je viens de
finir de lire rémy le chef qui est je
fais pas de pub j'ai aucune objection
mais si je peux je pense je pense ça
répond bien à toutes les questions qu'on
se pose sur ce qui se passe à gauche
parce que c'est ce qu'il faut désespérer
de la gauche en partant du constat que
effectivement il ya une extrême droite
extrêmement puissante ce même si lille
fragmenté est-ce que l'électorat de
gauche peut se réveiller et se dire il
ya un lien vote utile comme il ya pu y
avoir un vote utile en 2017 avec jean
luc mélenchon qui arrive en fin de
course avec eux on peut le dire aussi
lui il est en capacité de faire des
belles démonstrations de force de
meetings valley fait des belles
campagnes j'en ai plein champ général il
arrive à capter il fait de la pédagogie
je sais pas si ça sera le cas pour cette
élection là mais c'est vrai que
l'électorat de gauche on voit et c'est
pas moi qui je le pense pas et le
descendeur qui nous l'expliquent
aujourd'hui et une partie de l'électorat
gauche croit que c'est près de 30% qui
est prêt à voter pour emmanuel macron
parce que le danger aujourd'hui et tel
que l'extrême droite pourrait arriver au
pouvoir demain donc c'est la difficulté
à laquelle est confrontée la gauche
qu'il faut qu'elle arrive à se rendre
crédible audible pour être en capacité
de passer à la fois le second tour est
de battre emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
hélas j'ai le sentiment que ce n'est pas
possible il faut savoir d'où on part
parce que vous avez commencé à parler
d'un hidalgo et c'est vrai que la raison
pour laquelle les journalistes se
mettent à poser cette question anne
hidalgo sur la question des sondages
c'est qu'on en 2012 souvenez vous la
gauche en tout cas le père le parti
socialiste avait l'assemblée nationale
la majorité à l'assemblée nationale au
sénat inédit mon une sorte la vème
république donc évidemment c'était eux
qui étaient au pouvoir à l'élection
présidentielle françois hollande
williams ont maté de gauche des grandes
villes de gauche toutes les régions
presque à gauche et aujourd'hui à l'ats
signature de la socialiste à 2% sa part
est effectivement totalement surprenant
alors même que la social démocratie
aujourd'hui en europe en allemagne en
espagne au portugal se porte plutôt pas
trop mal donc je pense que anne hidalgo
pâtit évidemment et ça elle ne dit pas
suffisamment je le trouve du quinquennat
de françois hollande et ça je pense que
tout le monde en est conscient mais je
trouve qu'elle n'est pas suffisamment
critique peut-être elle ne se met pas
suffisamment retrait ou en tout cas
l'inventaire peut-être du parti
socialiste n'a t-il pas été suffisamment
fait pour que le parti socialiste
redevienne une force un peu crédible
avec un discours qui est dont elle dit
qu'elle est même plus radical parfois
que jean luc mélenchon donc pour en
arriver là il faut quand même que
l'inventaire était effet et ou en tout
cas qui a un beau regard critique parce
que quand bernard cazeneuve nous
explique que le parti socialiste n'a pas
fait n'est pas n'a pas suffisamment
travaillé bon ben il y aussi un désir
etc il est aussi un des réacteurs ou en
tout cas des responsables quand même de
l'état de la social démocratie en france
lé flanc radio un mot de conclusion sur
ce débat peut-être une réponse sur
l'inventaire mais je dirais que il ya un
élément de distorsion majeure
aujourd'hui qui est une partie de notre
inventaire hélas c'est emmanuel macron
tant que emmanuel macron restera en
responsabilité tant qu'il cultivera ce
en même temps totalement factice tant
que certains électeurs peu socialiser
peu politisés croire en encore qu'une
politique de gauche peut être conduite
par emmanuel macron qu'il est un rempart
contre l'extrême droite de fait une
partie de l'électorat de la gauche
social-démocrate d'une partie
l'électorat de gauche ne se retrouvera
pas dans les petits candidats
actuellement donc je pense qu'il faut
briser le mirage macron et une fois cela
sera fait je pense que on va arriver
peut-être un repos la risée une vie
politique avec des débats qui seront
plus sain et surtout beaucoup plus
porteur dans la transformation de la
société que ça peut prendre deux mois ça
où ça va prendre cinq ans et coûter
laissez-moi quelques mois pour vous
répondre on suivra sa merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat céline pina merci je rappelle le
titre de votre livre ses biens
essentiels c'est dans la collection
bouquins et c'est quoi le livre dont
vous nous parliez me lefebvre faut-il
désespérer de la gauche c'est vraiment
je trouve que très bien a expliqué on
comprend mieux pourquoi la bougie dans
cet état merci beaucoup nos invités
peuvent aussi nous conseiller des bons
livres merci alors participer à ce débat